tiny motion sensors known as
accelerometers are at the heart of much
of today's technology built into a
smartphone for example the sensor
detects both movement and the angle at
which the phone is being held to trigger
the rotation of the screen this little
chip is why a smartphone knows when it
has moved
these motion sensors are tiny but smart
because they can detect every move
they start with silicon discs called
wafers
each wafer will be used to make
thousands of motion sensors
technician aligns the discs in a
cassette using the flat part of each one
as a reference point
once properly aligned a mechanism lowers
the Silicon Wafers onto a carrier made
of quartz because it can withstand
intense Heat
the technician loads the Wafers into the
furnace
[Music]
side 1100 degrees Celsius heat and steam
cause an oxide to form on the surface of
each wafer
it'll act as an electrical insulator
[Music]
then it's into what's known as a sputter
system
here inert gas ions bombard aluminum
causing it to sputter onto the wafer
until an even layer accumulates
this aluminum layer will serve as a
conductor of electricity
the next machine deposits a light
sensitive chemical onto the wafer
the wafer spins allowing the chemical to
flow evenly across the surface
foreign
this all happens under the glow of
yellow light to prevent the untimely
activation of the chemical which reacts
to Bright Light just like an unexposed
photographic negative wood
[Music]
they're now ready for that bright light
UV light beams through tiny patterns on
a glass plate to activate the light
sensitive chemical
the patterns transfer to the wafer's
surface forming an outline for thousands
of motion sensors
another chemical then flows onto the
Silicon wafer to further develop these
minuscule images
[Music]
next lasers locate the wafer's flat Edge
signaling a Chuck to spin it into proper
position for plasma etching the etching
creates thousands of free moving 3D
structures each one is a motion sensor
after etching a sprayer blasts the
surface with carbon dioxide it's the
only way to clean it without damaging
the now movable sensors
at the next station a robotic arm flips
the wafer into position
a tray moves under the robot and it
places the wafer on it
the tray retracts and loads the wafer
into a clamping system
[Music]
it then collects a second silicon wafer
and places it on the first one in the
clamp
the second wafer acts as a lid to
protect the individual sensors
held in the clamp a machine heat seals
the two Wafers and the bond is complete
next a computerized saw cuts grooves
into the top wafer only while a steady
stream of water keeps the dust down
the saw exposes the aluminum layer on
the bottom wafer something that will
allow each sensor to make an electrical
connection
[Music]
a platform now moves the wafer a
millimeter at a time so that a probe can
test each sensor and confirm it performs
correctly this continues until every
sensor on the wafer has been tested
from a plain silicon wafer to a unit
that contains thousands of motion
sensors this process has taken three
weeks
[Music]
after the individual sensors have been
cut out and encased in plastic they're
ready for a final test
a robot loads each sensor into a test
socket the socket both tests the
sensor's performance and programs it to
customer specifications
a robot packages the sensors for
shipping
and once installed in phones tablets and
computers these motion sensors will be
ready for action
if you've been to an airport you've seen
mobile belt loaders on the tarmac they
drive from the terminal to the aircraft
align their built-in conveyor belt with
the entrance to the cargo hold then load
baggage or cargo on board when an
aircraft arrives they do all that in
Reverse to unload baggage or cargo
a turn of the control handle adjusts the
height of the front of the belt loader
enabling it to reach the cargo hold of
even the tallest aircraft
the rear height is also adjustable so
the Airport baggage handlers can set it
at a level comfortable for loading
the vehicle and the conveyor belt are
separate units in this part of the
factory workers construct the conveyor's
steel frame
they weld together all the steel parts
then grind all the weld seams flat so
that the belt will move over the frame
smoothly
workers install a cross member just past
the midpoint of the frame it will
connect with two sets of lift arms
installed in the vehicle one which
raises and lowers the front of the
conveyor the other which raises and
lowers the rear workers insert alignment
pins to position the cross member on the
frame correctly then weld it in place
the vehicle's chassis is also made of
welded Steel Workers blast the chassis
and conveyor frame with a metal abrasive
this removes rust and other debris
prepping the surface for paint to adhere
properly
they caulk all the unwelded seams to
prevent corrosion
then spray a coat of primer followed by
a coat of industrial grade paint in the
color the customer requested
once the paint dries assembly can resume
on the conveyor frame they installed the
motor which drives the belt there are
two options available this hydraulic
motor powered by the vehicle's engine or
an electric motor powered by battery
the motor rotates two large metal
rollers one at the front of the frame
the other at the rear
the belt wraps around these rollers so
that when they turn the belt moves
between the end rollers running the
entire length of the conveyor workers
install 58 smaller metal rollers these
form the floor of the conveyor and can
support up to a ton of cargo
the motor runs these rollers forward or
in Reverse depending on whether the belt
is loading or unloading the aircraft
the belt itself is made of high strength
Tire grade rubber with an anti-skid
texture on the surface
to be long enough to loop around the
seven and a half meter long conveyor
plus the end rollers the belt is 15
meters in length
the ends have teeth which fit into each
other like a zipper and fasten with a
metal pin
[Music]
elsewhere in the factory technicians
install components on the vehicle
chassis
first the front and rear axles
[Music]
then on each axle two wheels with tires
specifically designed for long life on
the airport tarmac
[Music]
at the rear of the chassis they install
the hydraulic cylinder which raises and
lowers the rear lift arms
then the vehicle's engine which can be
either gas diesel propane or electric
powered
the vehicle drives at a maximum speed of
just 43 kilometers per hour but that's
more than sufficient for traveling
between the terminal and the aircraft
after installing the power steering
system technicians run wiring for the
lights and other electrical components
run hydraulic hoses for the brakes and
lift cylinders and install the controls
for the conveyor
they install the hydraulic cylinder
which raises the front lift arms
then connect the fluid hoses to the
hydraulic pump
next they install the front and rear
lift arms along with the safety brace
underneath to use when mechanics are
working beneath the conveyor
they attach the lift arms to the front
and rear cylinders which expand to raise
the arms and retract to lower them
now workers Hoist the conveyor over the
vehicle and Bolt the front and rear lift
arms to the cross member on the
conveyor's underside
the two units are now one mobile belt
loader
ready to roll off the line and hit the
tarmac
[Music]